hey josh how you doing morgan i'm doing
great i
i have the beautiful sun behind me that
is causing us
a lot of problems this morning in sydney
it seems
so welcoming right it's making my camera
crew like work harder than they've ever
had to work in their life
so if it just suddenly seems like like
just
the i'm in the ark of the covenant uh
that's why
um so great to see you though nice to
see you you need to be in a dark
basement like me with my brother hiding
over there on his computer it's so much
easier beautiful setup beautiful setup
you got thank you
um so i wanted to say congratulations on
this show getting renewed for season
three before season two even came
out was that a nice pleasant surprise
for you um
it was you know we have been
working overtime to make this show
happen uh during quarantine uh i i
our artists our uh creative team
our runners um calvin and steven and
the entire group uh who who's
responsible for this music
they really made the impossible possible
and
and to be rewarded with a season three
pickup was um
was the greatest gift uh at a time when
i think
all of us were just pouring blood sweat
and tears into just making season two
happen
i can only imagine you know obviously
one of the best parts of this series are
musical numbers season one was so good
some of the catchiest songs
season two i swear i love the music even
more what do you love about music this
season
i i agree with you i i was very nervous
because i
am basically the one who's responsible
for
uh deciding that we needed to do this as
a musical and that meant four songs an
episode
and i thought we hit the bullseye season
one and then i was like oh god josh
what have we committed to now for season
two
and not only did i feel like we met the
challenge i think we surpassed it in
every way
the songs are i think so unbelievably
catchy
um you know there there's a song
available now on itunes
called we hawk and sung by the brilliant
to be diggs that
i think sets the tone for
what makes season two so special which
is it just goes to places musically
we've we've never really
um channeled before whether it's country
uh
whether it's um hip-hop there's all
sorts of stuff that we do
that is unexpected hopefully and uh
and i think really really exciting
yeah yeah such a good song i love you
brought that up um you know the
tillerman's are
always so entertaining i mean there's so
much love there but they're funny
and they're quirky and they kind of have
some potentially big decisions to make
this season what are you excited for
fans to see
well you know the tillerman's to me is
it's the harding beat of our show
yeah as as brilliantly bought brought to
life by leslie odom jr
um catherine hahn titus burgess and now
the brilliant emmy raver lantman
they're the beating heart they represent
uh passion
they represent love they represent um
fighting for what you believe in in the
face of adversity
and this year we've given them much more
adversity than even in season one
they have some big challenges in store
and those
stakes that are so high you know that
that not only revolve around the
possibility that they're going to lose
their home
but lose the park that means so much not
only to them
but to so many others is everything yeah
um well you know this the internet went
into meltdown mode when you posted
a picture of harrison ford on set of
indiana jones five where did you get
that picture and are you in the movie
i know okay i am not in the movie i
thought that picture was all over
and i posted it as a fan i i genuinely
am the biggest indiana jones fan i i
think raiders of the lost ark is a
perfect movie
and seeing harrison ford back
as that character uh honestly shook me
to my core
uh james mangled i think is one of the
great
uh directors out there right now i think
logan and ford versus ferrari are just
perfection um so i'm just i am
fangirling at the possibilities of what
indiana jones 5 might be
um i couldn't be more excited i couldn't
be more grateful that
that we get to experience uh another
round of the fedora and whip so i'm i'm
uh
i'm i'm ecstatic amazing just to wrap
things up luke evans and you reuniting
very soon how pumped are you
who's who's reuniting you and luke evans
for the
the beauty and the beast prequel series
we are this is the first i'm hearing it
this is gonna be so funny all over the
place uh
no i i am so excited
uh one of my favorite roles ever was
playing lefou to
uh luke's gaston and and um
eddie uh and adam our showrunners as
well as the incredible writing staff
as well as alamenkin uh have created
i think uh scripts that are going to
blow everyone's minds
uh expect the unexpected it is it is
truly going to be
um a journey into a tale of as old as
time
that goes places i i think uh that
is going to surprise a lot of people
yeah awesome well thanks so much josh
always so great getting to talk to you
great to see you thank you
you